et théodore monod vous dit quelque part
que vous détestez les guerres vous
trouvez que mec qu'il n'y a même pas de
guerre juste vous le dites vous trouvez
que donc la guerre là contre les nazis
s'étaient pas une guerre une fois non
mais il ya d'autres feuilles à pouvoir
revendre autre façon de résister à un
adversaire que la violence est à présent
jusqu'à présent on en a on s'est
installé dans cette ville et que seule
la violence pouvait répondre à une
hostilité jetés ailleurs et c'est ce pas
certain du tout jusqu'après les romains
avaient un dicsours stupide qui est
encore encore à l'ordre du jour si vis
pacem para bellum alors que le vrai
diction sait si vis pacem para patch
hommes et chez les romains fait la
guerre pendant 250 agents fait tous les
ans avec carbo dicton qui veut la paix
pas parler est ce que fait le pari de la
paix jules roy keane en face de vous qui
était un pilote de guerre etc
mais non mais c'est énorme est ce que
vous regardez post un homme tout à fait
étrange parce qu'il est étrange non ce
qui nous sommes l'admirable dans le cas
de joux le roi et de quelques autres pas
très nombreux malheureusement c'est
l'évolution que les amener de
l'acceptation de la violence et de la
barbarie les par conséquent la guerre à
une détestation profonde à la fois de la
violence de la torture de la justice et
par conséquent de la guerre je le roi
dit quelque part par quelque part de la
régie d'
rigide écoles l'arrivée d'une régie
d'école de la non pensée très bien sur
les épaules de quoi il s'agit d'une
seule bonne chose
de quoi il s'agit ça rejoint
immédiatement la belle parole d'einstein
celui qui est capable de marcher au pas
d'ailleurs une musique militaire n'a pas
besoin d'un cerveau moelle épinière lui
suffisent refuge l'euro
jean lacouture est ce que je pensais de
mire et d'hormones au j'admire beaucoup
l'homme mais mais réellement l'alleud
le refus de la guerre à au nazisme par
est une absurdité totale je me dire je
lui dis en tout respect il ya beaucoup
de guerre très injuste je pense qu'en
effet la guerre est majoritairement
injuste mais je pense qu'il ya eu une
guerre juste il justifié dans l'histoire
c'est celle qui a commencé en 1939 était
pas mieux je fais mieux enfin malraux
disait il ya des guerres justes il n'ya
pas d'armée innocente as et là je crois
qu'il enverrait